[Music]
so martin you remember how we were
talking about terraform
yeah katie it made me really want to try
it out
well how about we try out some terraform
provisioning right now sounds great
[Music]
so martin i can see you've got a new
project set up and you've configured
billing yes
yep that's right i have here martin's
projects and a bunch of
numbers yeah yep so if you open up the
source code i gave you over in github
all right there it is yeah and if you go
down to the readme there's all the
instructions you need to get it working
oh excellent my cat photo identification
service
all right uh billing enabled
launch cloud shell yep
so you can run all this in cloud shell
because it already has
gcloud locally and it also has terraform
locally installed as well and you can
get to the cloud shell by clicking that
little icon
in the google cloud platform console
so if you go to the readme there will be
a git clone command that you can
clone the source code into your cloud
shell
oh i love it when it's simple all right
let's see
copy that paste that git clone in there
okay
and then you want to go into the
expeditions directory and then the
terraform directory
okay very good
all right i'm there yep and so from here
there are three commands gcloud build
submit to create the container and then
two commands for terraform
all right gcloud build submit
oh i had set project
let's do that
and my project id is up here
authorize that
all right the build finished yep and now
it's just two terraform commands
first terraform init terraform
init very good
and now terraform apply terraform
apply
project id i have that in my copy buffer
uh well do i want to perform these
actions
what should i say here y e s for yes
yes let's do it and it's done
uh looks like uh it's a service url here
what's that
that's your running service oh
cool should i click it yeah
all right let's see
oh look i have cats
and we have some image labels here where
do these labels come from
so would you like to know what this
service does yeah please explain
so if you go back to the github repo
i've
got a architecture diagram listed on the
readme there right at the end
aha architectural diagram nice
so this is what's going on here what
we've done
is as we described in last week's video
we had to create a container first so we
used cloud build to create a container
that then stored that container in
container registry
and then we used terraform we have or i
already created a whole bunch of
manifest that would do
all the steps required but terraform was
going and
creating a whole bunch of iam
permissions service enablement and the
like
it then created a cloud run bucket and a
whole bunch of sample
cats that we saw it then created a
function and then it created a service
what we have is a service that goes
through all the images in a bucket
and for each of those images sends them
off to cloud functions
and asks cloud functions to talk to
the vision api to get information about
each image
in this case it's a cat and we're asking
it to describe
the image so it's coming back with
labels like cats whiskers and the like
those results then come back to cloud
run and then it displays all the results
in that lovely web page
nice so these four boxes were all
automatically deployed with that
one terraform apply command yep
easy isn't it yeah
so they're all in here somewhere in my
project now
yeah so if you want to go to cloud run
you can see
the service has been created yeah
let's see oh all right i see the cats
service here so you can see the service
has been created
because we did all this in terraform the
console is having to start from cold
oh i see yeah ah yeah i clicked on
revisions i see there's one revision
here it's getting 100 of the traffic
this is looking good yep we also created
the cloud run function which if you go
over to functions you can see that
there all right cloud functions let's
have a look
all right so i'm in functions ah we have
a
function called processing here yeah
uh-huh so here i can see the source code
of of that function that was part of the
project
yep and then the last major thing we did
was create the cloud storage bucket
and pre-populate it oh right
that's those cat pictures we saw a
minute ago right yep
all right we're in cloud storage the
bucket i created is the one that has
media on the end oh okay let's have a
look
uh-huh and it looks like some cat
pictures
yep so what i did in this case martin
is i created all these elements in
terraform but i also pre-populated the
bucket with some sample cats that way
you can see
that your service is working what we can
do now
is we can delete those cats because we
created them in terraform we can
recreate them again
so what we can do is remove those cats
and get terraform to recreate them for
us
oh cool let's try it
delete them all right feels a little
scary but i trust you
okay in this case terraform created this
sample data
so it can recreate this sample data
please do not go deleting everything
from your buckets
reload the surface first just to show
that the cats have gone away
all right okay so here was the cat
pictures oh i have no cats that's
awesome
no cats so if you go back to
cloud shell yeah the last command we ran
was tara from apply
so if you want to run that again and
maybe make the window a little bit
bigger because we're going to start
looking at some of the terraform output
now
oh okay cool uh there we go
let's see if i have the project yeah
project id in my copy buffer
so last time you may have noticed we
were creating 18 elements this time
we're only creating a smaller set of
elements
terraform is identified that our desired
state of the project requires us to
recreate these three images and some
other smaller bits of metadata
but ah you can type yes again
and get all the cats back oh yes let's
get the
oh that was quick all right so
if i hit the service over here now we
should hopefully see some cats
yeah the cats are back oh i love this
how i could
if anything went awry with the service i
could just easily recreate it
that's one of the powers of terraform
now there are some limitations to how
much terraform can save you from
misconfigured projects but this is an
example of how terraform can recreate
some of these resources
for you all right
cool uh i i have to keep on
entering the project id here that's a
little annoying can we do something
about that
we can um so what we'll do is we'll do
two things at once here
we'll get you to reapply terraform again
and we'll also get you to define that
variable so if you go terraform apply
but before you hit enter go space
hyphen v-a-r yeah
space project equals object
and then your project name ah i see
let's do that now
this is a working application here is it
safe to
run terraform apply again when
everything is working as it should
yup in theory terraform
will not see any changes or any changes
that it does see a little
tiny differences in metadata or
something that it doesn't control
but whenever you run terraform apply you
should just check what's going to be
applied and then if you're comfortable
with those changes type yes
why yes let's do it boom that was quick
would you like to destroy everything now
destroy
it sounds dangerous but we did get the
cat pictures
back before okay i'll trust you let's do
it
disclaimer in this case we are using a
brand new
separate project that we created with
terraform all the elements we created
with terraform
so now we're going to get terraform to
undo all the resource
creation that it applied so if you're
ready button
if you want to type terraform destroy
oh my gosh terraform destroy
like so yep and you're gonna have to
enter in your project as well
uh okay should we do this oops
or project
equals there it is all right
let's do it
18 things will be destroyed oh my gosh
we created 18 things now we're going to
destroy 18 things so if you're ready
martin
y e s and terraform will remove
everything that are created
oh my
all right so it's destroyed now if i hit
this
application the web page oh my gosh it's
not even i have no cats it's literally a
four or four it's the
url doesn't exist huh we destroyed
everything
wow uh okay how do i get it back
terraform apply oh really
okay let's do that
all right 18 things will be added it
says okay
let's do it
all right a terraform reply is all done
yep and your cats should now be back
oh let's see here so okay before i got a
404
error because the service had been
removed
ah the cats are back i'm relieved that
was really cool katie
did you want to take a look at what the
terraform manifests look like while
we're here
ah yes what's the magic that makes all
of this happen
not magic just the careful application
of configuration files
very good you can go to github or we can
use the uh cloud shell editor
all right um i'm going to github
uh i'll go up in the directory here
dot t f does that have anything to do
with it
yup dot t f is for terraform manifest
so there are a couple of manifests in
here the three main ones that are
standard names for terraform manifests
are the main which is the main file
variables for variables and then outputs
for outputs each of the other manifests
that i have there
for this demonstration are just a
logical separation of each of the
different components the function for
functions the service for service
media for media etc those folders that
i've got in there are
also just the source code so if you have
a look at the function
you'll end up with the requirements.txt
and the application file that you we saw
earlier
in cloud functions so that's just the
function code same for the service code
but it's those terrible manufactures the
cloud run service
yeah yeah uh-huh
cool but it's those manifests that
define
what we want our project state to be
oh i see they list the services and the
buckets and everything it's in these tf
files
yeah cool uh
so katie i have one more question for
you uh when i was running this terraform
reply it always asked me to input yes
y e s to actually make it happen
can i automate that away as well yes but
you can automate it away you can auto
approve
but when you're running terraform
locally you really should be checking
what you're doing
for automation pipelines and uh
continuous uh deployment you can't
have a human type why yes so there are
ways terraform can do that but when
you're learning
make sure that you actually go back and
read what terraform is going to do
especially
if you start destroying stuff just to
make sure that you're in the right
project
that you're manipulating the resources
that you expect
ah cool got it well i can't wait to
write some
terraform manifests and replaces these
long readme files i've been sending to
my customer
this is very exciting stuff thank you
for showing me katie absolutely no
worries martin
all right if thank you for watching and
if you have any questions or any
suggestions for new topics we should
bring up in these episodes please enter
them in the comments below
thank you bye
you